hi I'm Erik Bosse and adventures in game
love this 3000 by bringing us back to
the theaters for one last ride with
endgame well until the digital blu-ray
versions come out in a month but with a
special bonus
post-credit deleted scene for the movie
was it worth it well for a guy who owns
multiple Infinity Gauntlet yeah so I'm
gonna break down what this stuff was and
I know quickly because unlike me your
time is valuable and spoiler warning I
guess if you wanted to see this for
yourself but I feel like if you hit play
on this to listen to a nerd who spent
another 18 bucks on a three-hour movie
and hey a poster explained it to you
you're probably okay with this okay
after three thrilling hours of unchanged
end game because it is perfect this
rereleased ends with a heartfelt tribute
montage of Stan Lee on the sets of every
MCU film at least from what I could see
and then co-director Anthony Russo
introduces an unfinished deleted scene
from the film then we cut to a burning
building
firefighters sirens everything one
firefighter reports to his chief that
people are trapped on the 40th floor
chief asks where are those damn choppers
but this chief is the cameo by the
amazing Reginald veljohnson
of Family Matters Fame but more
importantly of diehard Fame he was the
cop at the base of the neck Kissimmee
Plaza and this would have tied in very
neatly with Scott Lang's mention of die
hard as a movie that actually didn't
include time travel but then the Hulk
leaps into the fire rescues the victims
using a satellite dish w kqj Atlanta
news 9 because infinity war an endgame
was shot in Georgia and the Atlanta area
Mark Ruffalo's voice plays over the
potato II unfinished CG I do dig ground
floor everybody out and this also would
have tied in with 2012 Hulk's anger at
being booted from the elevator during
the time heist
Spurs Hulk Banner then tells the chief
that the fire is burning at nine hundred
Kelvin which is about eleven hundred
sixty degrees Fahrenheit and recommends
use the inhale on bonds to extinguish it
then he gets a phone call go for Hulk
Steve who and sing so this deleted scene
would have most likely played before
Hulk banners reveal at the diner
remember eating pancakes sausages lots
lots of eggs this would have been the
reveal of Professor Hulk an end game
after cap and Scott mentioned finding a
bigger brain days after the in-game
release the screenwriters explained why
this scene was cut saying we did have a
scene illustrating more
deadly what the Hulk had been up to in
terms of being a hero as both soup just
starting it in the diner and explaining
things but it didn't give you anything
that you didn't get from just sitting
diner eating pancakes
and it came off more as noise than as
content the end results of this
exclusion in endgame is Hulk Manor being
more of a comedic figure you know a
walking clash of context who maybe
doesn't get a ton of singular action
moments
aside from snapping with the fancy glove
on but the reveal of big green allo at
the diner was just too priceless and you
know what I don't think we missed a
change
now this post-credits sequence also
includes a sneak peak scene to the
upcoming spider-man far from home but I
will break that down in a separate video
keep an eye out for it but comment down
below with your thoughts on this deleted
scene follow me on instagram and twitter
at EA bosses subscribe to new rock stars
for breakdown two theories about
everything marvel thank you for joining
me and guys a poster worth it
[Music]